what's the deal with airplane Peanuts
YouTube specials have completely changed
the comedy game over the past few years
with many Comics using the platform as
their only Outlet to independently share
and promote their work Shane Gillis
Andrew Schultz Mark Norman Ari shaffir
the Joe list goes on and on of great
comedians who have blown up their
careers by putting out killer YouTube
specials but it looks as if this brand
new system might already be in trouble
last night a very popular comedian had
his latest special lit up with YouTube
restrictions after debuting the new hour
on his channel less than two months ago
which had a lot of Comedy fans wondering
is YouTube still even the best place to
be the special titled Matthew Stephen
Rife debuted on February 14th but was
only up for 48 days before being deleted
from YouTube April 1st a lot of people
in the comedy world were surprised and
confused as to why the special was
removed in this clip listen to how Matt
Rife describes his experience with
YouTube versus how Christa Stefano talks
about working with Netflix we got hit
with a bunch of restrictions one of
which being an age restriction that
would require all viewers to be not only
proven that they're over 18 but they'd
have to have a registered official
YouTube account to be able to access it
which is insane considering most people
do not have a YouTube account that
defeats the entire purpose of YouTube
being such a shareable website and we
also got hit with a music a music
restriction for the song I paid
thousands of dollars for the rights for
um but they did not accept the
um
confirmation I guess if you want to call
it so it's completely dead in the
YouTube algorithm which means strangers
will never find it you guys can't watch
it unless you have an account so I have
to delete it's incredibly frustrated and
I'm very very sorry so for the few of
you who got to watch it I hope you liked
it I'll figure it out I look straight
into the camera I said I'm gonna kill
myself I swear to God
said nothing
I'm gonna kill myself and that
completely
Pete Lee was the warm-up comment you
know Peter dying laughing in the hallway
back he goes I can't believe you said
that he goes if Netflix has any balls
they'll keep that in I said well they do
have balls because in my special special
Wesley at the end of the Netflix I say
I'm putting this whole thing on YouTube
everybody but if Netflix wants to buy it
I'll sell it here and they let me keep
that in the special that's cool now
obviously not every single comedian even
has Netflix as an option for their
special but when thinking about the
future of Comedy it's very interesting
to see that there's potentially more
freedom in the corporate route than in
the independent one mattripe's YouTube
channel has over 400 000 Subs on just 31
videos and his previous special received
over 4 million views so it's definitely
not like nobody was gonna see this new
one it's totally possible that this Matt
Rife special could have been comparable
in views to some of the best on this
platform and now it's just gone
this has to be the worst feeling ever
getting restricted by YouTube on a video
that you worked so hard on is already so
frustrating and helpless feeling but I
could not even imagine how shitty it
must feel for Matt Rife to get his
full-length special censored after all
the work he's put into crafting this
hour of material dude like I said I live
in L.A now it's the [__] worst
Brothers No Good People
a bunch of [__] heathens running
around nobody's going to heaven not one
person City of Angels No Angels
just depressing man it's so depressing
getting let down every time like I just
expect it at this point every first day
I'd go on as soon as I sit down I'm like
all right [__] what is it ask me ask me
what my sign is I dare you I'll split
this check so [__] fast I swear to
God oh you're a Pisces awesome yeah
charge it to her crystals they were in
the moon all night last night securely
their true stuff even Beyond just the
jokes the entire process of spending big
money to film and produce an independent
special pouring countless hours into
editing and promotion and just feeling
reliable to your fans after hyping up a
release date and now for [__]
reasons completely out of your control
that's all gone
and even if he does figure out the music
thing or bleep out some cuss words or
whatever YouTube is looking for to keep
their precious safe viewers away from
Matt rife's verbal terrorism it's just
not going to be the same the whole
process of releasing a new special
creates excitement for the fans and
there's Buzz around that comic leading
up to the premiere it's not like some
random YouTube video that you can delete
and re-upload a few days later and no
one will care this is a whole Year's
worth of work just down the drain for
reasons I don't think any of us
understand including the people at
YouTube like just watch any popular rap
music video on this platform that
YouTube has no problem with then please
tell me why Matt Rife special requires
any restrictions I don't know about you
guys but when I click on a YouTube video
that I don't like I just stop watching
it never once have I thought to myself
well gosh darn it YouTube better do
something about this before someone else
gets hurt by all these jokes [__]
[__]
the roast of Burt Chrysler took place on
Saturday April 1st on only fans TV at
first when I heard this was going to be
on only fans and produced by Whitney
Cummings I honestly thought this was
just some big cash grab to get us all
subscribed to Whitney's only fans but
what a pleasant surprise it was to find
out the entire hour-long roast is
actually free to watch the comics on the
panel roasting Bert include Tom Segura
Tony Hinchcliffe Donna Rawlings Big Jay
oakerson Jim Norton Rachel Feinstein
Whitney Cummings and Trevor Wallace was
the host whether you're a fan or a hater
of Bert Kreischer I guarantee there's
something in this roast that you will
find funny for the Die Hard Bert fans
there's plenty of hilarious references
to inside jokes throughout his career
and for those who find Birch stick
annoying there's even more jokes about
that but you also have one of my
favorite jokes and you guys have
probably heard it in every one of his
specials
starts with take off his shirt blah blah
blah
some situation comes up that isle is in
and then Isla says and I quote
[Applause]
[Music]
dot dot dot something you made up that
Isla said
design was great the editing was Top
Notch overall it seemed like a ton of
work and turned out to be a very big
event and successful roast that had a
lot of money behind it which is ironic
because just 10 days before this came
out the flagrant crew was able to
completely destroy Bert's entire
existence with only a few balloons right
it says
[Laughter]
who loves you so much
can we leave one balloon give me the
beer give me the verse
they're really gonna pop that's what
they really are because they're really
like
but it's okay you're safe now you're
safe round two of this year's comedy
podcast March Madness Tournament is
currently underway over at
watchcomedy.live this is the second year
in a row that we've done this tournament
but what's really great to see is this
time we actually have some podcasts like
we might be drunk and Chrissy chaos
getting involved in urging their
audiences to help them win this thing
which is super cool you can go vote on
the funniest clips right now and help
your favorite podcast win maybe the most
prestigious award in all of
entertainment the joke World comedy
podcast March Madness Tournament
presented by watchcomedy.life Champion
we uh we definitely need a shorter name
for that guest spots from last week your
mom's house did not have a guest two
bears one cave was Burton Tom and Burton
kill Tony this week was with the young
bull Shane Gillis whiskey ginger head on
Rick Glassman Russell shorto was on
Christy chaos Sam Talent was on Matt and
Shane's secret podcast and Tim Dylan was
on footstog radio I'm sitting in in the
the studios of the Tim Dillon show
interviewing
Tim Dylan which uh I think might be my
new thing maybe I go to other people's
podcasts
and I interview them
and uh do it on their set and ask the
questions that
there may be maybe there's questions
that your listeners would want to hear
yeah you turn the tables turn the tables
I like it that's what it's called I like
it turn the tables with Greg Fitzsimmons
yeah and and it it builds until finally
I'm sitting there with Fallon yeah and
I'm saying why are you why are you still
moving forward what's the momentum
what's carrying you you know what drives
you
this past weekend with Theo Vaughn had
on Nate bargatzi and Mike vecchione The
Joe Rogan Experience talked with smart
people this week no comedians Brooke
Chrysler was on take her shoes off he
was also on stavy's world Samurai was on
the blocks podcast Sam J was on we might
be drunk Adam Rowe was on are you
garbage and Mike vacchione was on you
know what dude
as far as new stand-up specials Go Big
Jay oakerson and Ryan sickler both have
specials coming out Wednesday April 5th
those will be on YouTube Louis CK has
his newest special out right now on his
website available for just ten dollars
and John Mulaney Baby J is coming to
Netflix on April 25th we also have Matt
ripe's latest special being pulled off
YouTube to be re-uploaded I assume
sometime later this week in all 45
episodes of the joke World comedy news I
don't think we've ever had an update on
one less special to watch historic stuff
today folks
make sure to go vote on your favorite
podcast clip to advance in our March
Madness bracket there's a chance we can
start doing more of these moving forward
maybe with the best of the month Clips
if you guys like the voting thing I
don't know I'm just trying to create
more ways for you to interact with your
favorite podcasts and your favorite
comedians besides just watching the
videos and subscribing to their channels
oh speaking of subscribing to YouTube
channels please touch my button through
the fence
[Music]